when a mother sea turtle lays her eggs
in the beach sand
she doesn't stick around to protect them
and even if the eggs survive long enough
to hatch as few as one percent of
hatchlings will survive to adulthood
many don't even make it into the water
here's why the baby sea turtles look
like a good snack for all kinds of birds
just waiting for those eggs to hatch
here a black vulture takes a bite at the
hatchlings it seemingly is chucking out
one at a time looking for just the right
one to eat vultures are scavengers and
they'll eat just about any formerly
living creature they can find along the
beach then there are frigate birds they
don't even need to land when they hunt
Turtles they just swoop down and pick up
the baby turtles then from the sand come
hungry crabs they just want to pull the
turtle down into the sand with them
where they can dine in private
maybe so the sea birds won't steal their
meal